après un long hiver confiné à londres
certains britanniques ont bravé la neige
et le froid de longues heures d'attentes
sur oxford street pour ne surtout pas
rater la réouverture des magasins
je suis arrivé à jd sports à 3 heures du
matin afin de faire la queue pour
acheter des chaussures
ce fut un flop après j'ai fini par venir
ici et je fais la queue depuis et mec ça
gèle sage et lisse c'est agréable vous
savez de pouvoir venir acheter ce que
l'on veut de sortir avec des amis et
c'est comme retrouver une vie normale
comme tout le pays
l'artère la plus commerçante d'europe et
ses 300 boutiques reprenne vie
c'est vraiment agréable on en a parlé on
a marché ici et c'est presque comme si
londres revenait à la vie
c'est bizarre on avait l'impression que
les rues étaient justes mortes et
maintenant c'est agréable de voir des
gens sourire s'amuser pour une fois dans
un premier temps les salles des
restaurants les hôtels les salles de
spectacle et les stades vont rester
fermés mais désormais les anglais
peuvent se retrouver autour d'un café ou
d'une pente en terrasse
c'est vraiment surréaliste j'ai un peu
l'impression de déjà vu parce qu'on
avait tout arrêté et recommencer tant de
fois on a l'impression d'être revenu à
l'été dernier je n'ai pas l'impression
que c'est vraiment réel pour le moment
il faut du temps pour réaliser après six
mois six 6 mois à être enfermés à
l'intérieur pour enfin sortir entouré de
gens avec une bonne ambiance et c'est
juste génial
combien de pinte au autant qu'il en faut
pour finir par terre tomber dans le
caniveau
je m'en fiche tout le monde se sentait
un peu déprimé maintenant tout le monde
semble être heureux vous voyez les
sourires qui commencent à apparaître sur
les visages des gens ces deux derniers
jours c'est comme si c'était le vrai
printemps c'est le vrai printemps avec
une ville ouverte
un avant goût de la vie post qu'ovide
rendu possible grâce à une campagne de
vaccination particulièrement efficace
depuis son lancement au mois de décembre
dernier les chiffres sont sans appel
près de 60 % des adultes britanniques
ont déjà reçu une première dose de sérum
si les conditions sanitaires le
permettent
la prochaine étape du déconfinement aura
lieu le 17 mai prochain